dans les cinq premiers mois je prenais
pas vraiment au sérieux trichet plus
souvent qu'après ça et j'ai perdu ma
première au lycée j'ai vu que whaou
si je fais attention ces jurys perdu
mais à plus long terme je prends avant
des résultats vraiment satisfaisant
jallet forte là dessus c est vraiment
déterminée puis c'est ce que j'admire
beaucoup des lieux avec l'aide d'une
nutritionniste d'une infirmière et d'un
médecin
marino a dû modifier ses habitudes de
vie et améliorer ses compétences
culinaires chaude plus des repas suivi
au centre circuit sauf y avait aussi des
problèmes à maintenir un poids santé
avant de venir ici je pensais vraiment
que si je mangeais pas une journée puis
je mangeais une journée sur deux ça
allait faire que ça ait changé quelque
chose vraiment paul sportive aguerrie
elle a dû revoir son alimentation après
un accident de ski du jour au lendemain
j'ai arrêté tout mais sport je suis
conscient manger comme l'athlète même si
j'étais plutôt sédentaire
une équipe multidisciplinaire a passé en
revue la qualité du sommeil de sophie
les activités physiques et la nutrition
de toute la famille mois mais des fois
je pense à emmener commune barton donc
on va travailler petit à petit sur
différents objectifs au courant des deux
ans et normalement près deux ans on ne
transmet beaucoup d'informations
beaucoup de compétences à la famille
pour qu'ils puissent ensuite continué à
maintenir de saines habitudes et marilou
est suivie par l'équipe du docteur saint
pierre depuis une elle se rend avec un
membre de sa famille à la clinique
toutes les quatre à six semaines
je consommais manteau de boissons
gazeuses que vraiment trop truc ce crime
nous allons fixer ce premier objectif là
à l'aide d'une entrevue motivationnelle
en disant aux jeunes tout simplement
est-ce que tu serais prêt à nous faire
confiance
un mois a cessé toute consommation de
boissons sucrées
puis on se revoit donc sur quatre
semaines c'est un objectif qui est très
réaliste les enfants canadienne de 2 à 8
ans ingère en moyenne 115 g de sucre
chaque jour c'est cinq fois plus que la
quantité recommandée par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
le sucre est une drogue à laquelle notre
société s'est habitué les enfants
n'arrivent pas à dépenser toute cette
surconsommation la de sucre mais c'est
sûr que quand arrive la balance s'il
vous vient le stress
[Musique]
confronté à une image corporelle souvent
inatteignables les enfants en surpoids
vivent souvent du découragement c'est dû
au sida être dans un magasin préféré
puis de prendre la plus grande taille de
profiter d'un c'est surtout quand on est
ado t on vous saviez coulon vrai bien
dans notre loge puis ouais ça donne un
petit coup de poing dans face souvent
dit juste que je suis correct de
m'accepter comme je suis de pas vraiment
regardé le chef puis vraiment regarder
comment je suis dans mon vêtement que
c'est pas lécher sur la balance ce qui
est important mais vraiment à quoi je
ressemble c'est très important de
reconstruire cette estime de soi là de
façon graduelle malheureusement on n'a
pas tous les outils on sait que d'avoir
un psychologue compétents au niveau de
la relation de la personne envers la
nutrition c'est c'est essentiel à la
thérapie de ces jeunes là c'est prêt
pendant que les listes d'attentes
atteignent des sommets inégalés
les cliniques survivre grâce à des
levées de fonds sans financement des
gouvernements
si vous suivez quatre fins reconnaître
qu'on a reçues sur une période de six
mois quand dans les années antérieures
on va ça va à peu près 200 requêtes par
année donc on a plus de doubler le
nombre de requêtes dans les six derniers
mois puis on peut voir renvoi de trois
fins personnes par année
récemment plus de 200 pédiatre signé une
lettre adressée au premier ministre
françois legault pour demander au
gouvernement de s'engager à lutter
contre ce qu'ils considèrent comme une
épidémie de santé publique
aujourd'hui c'est la voix des parents
qui s'adresse à lui
devant l'absence de réponse du premier
ministre
la clinique 180 a tenu une conférence de
presse avec le soutien des familles pour
implorer le gouvernement d'egypte
de l'autre côté nous avons interpellé la
ministre de la santé et des services
sociaux danielle mais cannes qui nous a
répondu
l'obésité particulièrement celles qui
touchent les enfants est une
préoccupation importante en santé
publique
aussi les efforts de notre gouvernement
sont tournés vers l'éducation et la
prévention
notre politique gouvernementale de
prévention en santé contiennent de
nombreuses mesures qui contribueront à
lutter efficacement contre l'obésité est
un fléau responsable de nombreuses
maladies chroniques mais aucune mention
sur le traitement de la maladie
je pense que ça prend des patients des
familles qui souffrent et qui exige
d'avoir des soins de santé qui exige que
la maladie soit reconnue qui exige que
les gouvernements actuels cesse de faire
l'autruche et sortent la tête du sable
et reconnaissent la maladie pourtant
après deux ans de suivi la méthode
proposée par six cliniques fait ses
preuves
sam écrit une bonne base je vais
continuer à suivre mes plans d'action
puis ça va faire que je gardais ses
habitudes de vie tout au long de ma vie
à la clinique 180 on y va lui-même le
taux de réussite à 80% quand on peut
remettre notre beau chandail rose de
l'an passé où quand on doit acheter des
nouveaux pantalons parce qu'ils sont
trop grands ou parce que quelqu'un nous
a dit waouh est court plus vite dans ton
cours d'éducation physique était
grandement améliorée ce sont là les
vrais succès qu'on doit associer à une
alimentation plus saine puis à la
disparition de la maladie
où